oh so here's what i'm going to do this
is a great idea i'll do all that
but here's the thing i'm not even going
to change my voice i'm not even going to
try
but uh i'm going to be like some woman
that just wants to get waxed
well there's a wax center and there's
also a plastic surgeon so
i like the waxing okay okay so uh
the waxing center could you put the
number tell you the number and you'll
beep it out
um i could see is that that first one
yeah the wax center okay got it
all right let me just get this on here
so i'm calling a wac center and i'll use
all the information that i just got
can you hear it there it is turn the
volume up a little bit
hi thank you for calling me yeah hi um
i want to come in for a wax but i'm
really uncomfortable
i'm older now so you know what happens
when you get older the
tissues often thicken the colors uh
change and the uh right the inside
the flap from the inside is gone to the
outside which pulls a lot of the hair
that i have
and and got it and then well
okay you you don't want me to okay go
ahead
no no no no go ahead all right i'll just
start again
so on you know i'm older now i'm in my
uh
60s actually and you know how the
the round the vaginal area you can
change color and the skin
thickens and sometimes the you know i'm
trying to be
uh politically correct here but
think of the clitoris like an iceberg
okay where most of it is
it goes down the tube it's pulling the
hair there can you wax that
i'm so sorry can you repeat that one
more time all right i'm in my 60s and
you know how the uh
the vagina will change colors and some
of the tissues thicken and the clitoris
is more like a
uh like a uh an iceberg where the tip
just goes up
and and then the bottom is more
like you know some people say go in the
back but i don't
and the thing is that it pulled the hair
in there and i'd like to get it waxed
so can you do that
i'm sorry we uh we don't do male
brazilians
male 1 no i'm not asking for a male
brazilian
i'm asking just to be waxed around my uh
vaginal area what do you
i don't understand what you're saying
okay give me one
second do you mind if i place you on a
brief hold
okay but i'm not getting younger sorry
about that okay put me on hold for a
second and then i'll
but should i just hang on here
yeah you're more than welcome to i just
give me one second okay
or if you'd like i can go ahead and give
you a call back no i'll hang on i will
hang on
and then uh because i i'm not getting
younger
you know us ladies we just uh
it's not like wine we don't get uh
better with age you know what i'm saying
i understand our vagina will change
color
thickening and ice cream okay okay give
me one
serious about that all right take a
second
limited edition waxing essentials kit
featuring many versions of our slow it
body wash and lotion
and for the first time ever a smooth me
ingrown hair serum rollerball
better yet all three come in a summer
clutch sure to brighten your day
a summer clutch
[Music]
this is real how much hold how busy
could she possibly be
the middle of the afternoon is there a
busy time for waxing
maybe lunch breaks excited to welcome
you back into our centers and provide
you an exceptional experience why are
you looking at me like that
so when when you're one of the people
that work at this place and then you
take a lunch break and you go and you
find a hair in your salad it's probably
from your own workplace right
yeah well i'm just saying
should i call back and just get it on
the phone again maybe
what could possibly be do you think
she's just trying to lose me or she's
take
trying to find society to welcome you
back into our offenders and provide you
energy
experience okay i'm gonna call back
thank you for calling yeah hi
uh was i just on the phone with you yes
i have to
place you on a brief hold i'm i'm sorry
about that okay my name's cindy can i
get a why why do i have to go on hold i
mean i'm just
i'm telling you we have customers in the
front i know
but just killing me what's happening is
i'll explain to you again
as i get older the tissues are
thickening and where the clitoris is
it's like an iceberg and it pulled all
the hair in
over my labia and it's like a fold and i
want to do
i don't like it to look like that and
what i'd like to do
is is there such a thing and i don't
know the term for it but i want to get
the front
like wax but not the back of my vagina
like kind of a vaginal mullet is what
i'm looking for
you can ask for a um like specific spots
to be waxed does that make sense
like it doesn't have to be like the the
brazilian or the bikini full or bikini
line
what what would the what would the uh
proper term for a vaginal mullet be
i'm not too sure i'm not too sure what
that would well i want it short
i want it like short in the front and
then the back of the labia i'd like it
like long like at the back
um let's see okay because we only we
only remove hair
so we don't like trim oh there's no
trimming
there's no trim oh
oh because as i've i don't know
as i get older the uh flesh thickens
and the clitoris is like an iceberg
and it that the top is not really it's
about what's inside that deepens it
so that when the thickening and the
changing of the color and that the hair
gets grabbed
it's pulled in so i just need a quick
trim and a wax
yes okay unfortunately we don't do the
trim but we then i'll tell you what
all right so then i'll i'll tell you
what we'll leave the waxing off and if i
just come in for just a
complete trim and i'm out what time can
i come in
um are you what day are you looking to
come in because i don't have anything
available for the rest of the day i'm
fully booked
oh but um the hair is just
it's gotten crazy and especially now
with the humidity
you know yeah and yeah unfortunately i i
can't take you in today i'm fully booked
for the rest of the day
uh what about do you do any uh vaginal
bleaching
do we do any what i'm sorry you're
breaking up bleaching vaginal bleaching
because the color no we only do we only
do
we only do waxing here can i get my
is there any way that i can get the
vagina the my vagina bleached
no we only do uh the waxing all right so
i'll just come in for a trim and a
bleach and then
and then and then can you fit that in
today and then we can
i can't i can't take you in today i'm
fully booked for the rest of the day oh
because i'm not gonna
do it but it's just a trim and a bleach
so that it would be that should be quick
right
no i'm sorry we are fully booked for the
rest of the day so i can't take you in
today i can't however take you in
tomorrow
okay before breakfast uh
the earliest time i have tomorrow would
be at 12 30. no no no no i need to get
it done before breakfast because it's
important that i eat and i can't eat
while i'm getting my vagina bleached or
the hair around there
trimmed okay we don't do bleaching or
trimming we only do waxing if you'd like
you're more than welcome to call another
location we do have multiple
around here if you'd like maybe they can
come in and they're
maybe they can have an available
appointment for you i just don't have
any time
today but my books are fully booked all
right so what if we just did it
like at the end of the day today just a
bleaching
and a trim unfortunately i don't have
anything for the
end for today i only have to go let's go
tomorrow all right before breakfast
tomorrow how about just a trim
i don't i don't have a week before
breakfast i only have
a 12 30 and we only do waxing here
well i'm looking for trimming and
bleaching
unfortunately we don't do trimming or
bleaching we only do waxing if you'd
like to look up
on the internet about someone that can
help you out with that you're more than
welcome
i got you you were referred to me as
like one of the best salons in all of uh
woodland hill so i'm gonna come in today
and i'll just want a quick trim and a
bleach
no and i can't take you in today okay
tomorrow do you have something before
breakfast
i don't have anything before breakfast i
only have the 12 30.
all right then i'll stick with today
okay
we can't see you in today i'm sorry oh
i'm sorry i didn't hear that i didn't
hear that all right tomorrow
before breakfast just a trim and a
bleach
unfortunately i don't have anything for
tomorrow you're more than welcome to
contact my manager that's fair no i
don't want to deal with management i'll
come in i'll i i
at least i hear what you're saying i'll
come in today just for the no no
no no no i'm sorry you can't come in
today and
you are more than welcome to come in at
12 30.
all right but you cannot but i don't 12
30 is kind of late i want to get it done
before breakfast if i can get just a
chance
okay you're more than welcome to call
another location okay
well i want this location you have been
nothing but helpful and that's what
i was referred to by a friend that's why
i like this location
and this is where i'll come in so you
just call it i can either come in
tonight today for a trim or bleach or i
can come tomorrow what's the better time
you i can't take you in today i can take
you tomorrow
at 12 30 my earliest appointment and i
can only we can only service you for a
wax
i wanna but i wanna trim in a bleach
i understand but i can't take you
because we only
do i know waxing here oh so then
well that's tomorrow so today can you
take me in for a trim in a bleach
tonight
no i can't i'm sorry all right well just
just tell me that so then i'm just going
to set it up for tomorrow
tomorrow what time can you do it before
breakfast
oh 12 30. you can't do it before
breakfast
no just for a tremendous bleach
waxing at 12 30. but i
why would you force that on me like why
would you force me to be waxed i don't
want to be waxed i want to be true i'm
not forcing you to be laughing well
you're telling me to come in at 12 30
then you're forcing wax on me i don't
want to i
you you know it's my vagina and the way
i want to take care of my vagina
is me so absolutely
for anything other than a wax because
that is the only that's the only service
that we
do here are your nails
are your nails trimmed i'm sorry i
i can't i can't help you i can't i can
only give you the 12 30 appointment for
tomorrow for a waxing
oh okay so tomorrow's waxing so can i
come in tonight for a
trim and a bleach
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to give you my
manager's phone number because i
i can't help you i don't know oh i can't
oh i'm just writing it down okay let me
uh
let me write that down so are we just to
be clear are we on
for today for a trim
so tomorrow you're saying tomorrow a
trim in a
color a bleach no no no oh no
oh before breakfast
i'm writing it down okay no no i'm so
sorry i'm gonna have to
hang up now and my manager will contact
you if you give me your phone number
well why do i have to talk to the
manager you told me you have an
appointment tomorrow
i do have an appointment for tomorrow
but you're not understanding and i can't
oh i understand so tomorrow you're
saying a trim
and a uh bleach
why don't you hang up on me why do you
think
some people have absolutely no
patience and i don't understand it we're
all in this together people
[Music]
anyway
you